how is it like performing the new album
and
people already know the words and [__]
yeah it's crazy guys first time like i
performed on my old songs like three
years it's the first tour like uh
been able to [__] you know switch
jesus don't put that on facebook yeah
yeah
for real that'll be
have you seen the progression in the the
the type of chicks that are
the bigger you've gotten the type of
chicks that are down
no
um i know you're working on an ep right
now right
album wasn't it supposed to be an ep it
was and i realized like strange is only
doing six releases next year
so like so yeah
so you gotta do it gotta do it all
some of the joints like
frustration with coming up with [__] to
write about as you talked about what
you're talking about so much in life
like when you hit that that that that
writer's block or like you know how
often does that happen i mean what's
your writing process i hate writer's
block damn it every time i write this
i'm having like an amazing day but now
with me like i got i got like 20 tracks
together so i just kind of like
hum up concepts for hooks and choruses
and uh you know so now when i can get
um
lots of fireballs yeah
now but um i know that that you had said
that like you came off tour you got the
whip
you know what i'm saying you have some
bread the album came out you sold some
units
you know
you know right now you're not still in
the same situation you know and it's a
[__]
you know so hopefully after this try and
get
um
do you have any sort of like dialogue
general relationship with people
we spoke on twitter
um
they haven't opened up the red carpet
yet so they're driving us around the
circle
i'll jump you off here i drop you off
here get down my car
it takes a
red
carpet out and the champagne and crown
came on me at once it's like red's over
here
to fight this guy yes
i'm one of the people slurring yeah i
even shouted myself out on the red
carpet
artists looking like little
i was acting
i was really like it's never going to
happen again i'm drunk and they were
like nah rich you can't go in i'm like
[__] that i go in the lady tried to grab
my jacket i did a spin move on
security comes chasing me yo i really i
really it would have it might have been
a good
it was great man the whole the whole
experience was amazing man um
it was awesome dog i mean i'm second
growing people down who are you sitting
who knows around
was next to me lula rick ross
uh behind me they were like
behind me like i was like
a lot of people were like far back and i
felt like
what's going on i got to ask you man
because like
i'm always i've been up on your [__]
forever you know what i'm saying that
i've been putting people on you forever
so like
i feel like i have like a
biased outlook on on how tight you are
and how big you are
and then when i like every time you come
to town or when i finally see
[__] like giving you
recognition like it's like
cool
but like from like from like my
perspective
i'm just curious when you're at the bt
awards and you're meeting with all these
huge [__] like who like gave
you dabs we were like you know like
there's something
that gave me dabs and i think there was
a lot of people
you know i mean
it was weird that was i mean there was i
didn't really get to see i got more like
looks like
that [__] was kind of crazy
looking like red hair of course wrong
yeah
like dude
i was like i didn't give a flying
um
recorded the cipher i know it's like
i've always heard that like
there's a lot of there's a lot of takes
yeah
no they didn't like they did like eight
takes
so you don't know like what they're
gonna pick so you might have been out of
breath
how did the lineup come to be because i
feel like you guys all share some fans i
think it just makes sense man
i think we're like hot right now like
you know
is
of course i'm working on burn one of
nice hey the bow tie record and you and
wolf with that new talent
man look that whole [__] is dope that
whole [__] ep is well freaked out
like two days before it was like
supposed to release it man i need this
this song's about chevy's gifts yeah i
need to get that that's what's up man we
appreciate you rick's my dude i
appreciate you always you already know
thank you for like
go get the album go get my [__]
album
next year get the other out
boom
you